certain states are experiencing more and
more earthquakes particularly Oklahoma
which has seen a steady rise in
earthquakes over the past decade the
cause well research points to fracking
peter pelican is an analyst for
bloomberg intelligences energy team and
he joins us now right to have you with
us first of all good morning wait how do
you think I mean is this I mean is this
just telling us all something that we
kind of knew and there's just the
scientific data to prove it or what's
gone this is basically what's happening
the scientific data is catching up with
antidote so what's been happening is
there's been a growing relationship
between earthquakes in oil and gas
activity now one of the clear
misconceptions that I need to clear up
here is that it's the fracking or the
hydraulic fracturing that's causing the
earthquakes that's actually not the case
what the culprit really is is the waste
water that's being pulled out of these
oil and gas wells truck some distance
and inject it deep underground in
disposal wells that's the real culprit
there's the removal process I mean it is
still part of the fracking process is
causing absolutely seismic events but
it's not the initial process it's the
byproduct exactly so what is the
solution if there I mean it doesn't hate
do we need to find a solution is this I
mean obviously I mean I don't know why
but I tell me do you want earthquakes in
water cleaner to suppose that definitely
is a clear solution meaning we
definitely need to recycle more water
but one of the big problems that you
have is we're talking fast quantities of
water for each barrel of oil you produce
for example you can pull it as much as
10 barrels of water that is worse than
the ratio of water to almonds is it is
pretty bad it is pretty bad to get back
by the way well we all know that one so
and one of the issues with the water
that they're pulling out is that it's
very saline which means that it's
incredibly salty it's actually saltier
than seawater so actually using it for
productive means is very difficult right
so i think the game changer in this
space for this issue would be economical
desalination right now we're not there
but if you could do that you could then
use this wastewater for more productive
you could effectively cost-effectively
desalinate water use the world's
problems me that's like the game changer
rather couldn't you could use the
natural gas in the oil that you get out
of the fracked well in order to build
the desalination plant to clean up the
water
now you're on what does this mean future
of oil and gas in America well really
what it means is a tougher regulatory
environment I mean the real issues that
these companies face from this issue are
really two full one like I mentioned the
regulatory environment and second is
really potential lawsuits you know these
are activities that are causing real
damages so both of those could impact
you know the cost structures of these
businesses going forward in some can you
now say that fracking is causing
earthquakes based on the evidence that
I've analyzed I can say that wastewater
disposal wells which is part of the
fracking process is linked very strongly
to earthquakes and evidence that i might
point out a Stanford study came out
recently which confirmed some research
that we've done that definitively links
it oh all right then where can people
check out this report the research is
available on the Bloomberg terminal for
terminal subscribers and we hope
everyone checks it out alright